紐とかね殺したくなるよねちゃんと男に
なろうそれが自分たちが助かる道
だ女は男を求めてくるんよ男は女を求めて
いくんよだからお前が男になっときゃもう
遅いけど
なまあ頑張ろうよ君たちの時代
[音楽]
やYouTube見てくれてる若者に伝え
たいメッセージがあればいただきたいです
そうですねあの1番問題になるのは男の力
ということねあの円安がいつまたっても
続くというのは国力が低下したからでしょ
何もあの競争力だけの問題ではないんや
けどね国力が低下したからなの国力という
のは日本の男の力を全部合わせたやつや女
じゃ
ないもう女に頼るのはよせ自分たちの責任
だと思ってちゃんとやらにゃしっかり
働けこれはねうちに
来る生徒の中にはひどいのがあって将来の
希望って書かせるとね紐とか
ね
え殺したくなるよ
ねせっかく男に生まれてねその役目はまさ
ん会からちゃんと男になろうそれが自分
たちが助かる道
だ我々はまあ戦前の人たちがいい社会を
日本を作ってくれてその中で能々と暮らし
ちまったでノノと暮らしちまったおかげで
我々の次の世代これのトレーニングを忘れ
たよねであのトレーニングしようとすると
イラんお世話だなんて言い出しでなもう
リベラルが流行っちまったもんコミに騙さ
れるんじゃないあいつらは何にも分かって
ない何の責任も取ろうとしてないね叱ら
れるということ叱るということこれが悪い
ことだと言っとるけどとんでもない叱ら
れるおかげで人間は素晴らしくなるから
ちゃんと叱られたらま無茶にるやはいかん
のやけどちゃんと叱られたら感謝
せありがとうございましたと言って
みせそのためには叱られたおかげで自分が
進歩したという実績がいるん
だだから叱られたらふくされずに次叱られ
ようにしようと思って進歩するん
やそれが自分のためになるん
だか今からもっとひどい競争社会に
なる落ち込まれたらもうはい上がれ
ない
[音楽]
頑張れよだからこの前来たのが言ってた
もう40にもなってやってきてなんで今頃
来たんやい女の子に出ないからこれだと
一生結婚もできないいわゆる自分の女が
できない
どうしたらいいんでしょう簡単や男になれ
女は男を求めてくるに男は女を求めていく
んやだからお前が男になっ
ときゃ誰かは寄ってくる
ぜだけど寄ってきた女の面倒をちゃんと
見れるようにしとかないから小食もせえよ
な金も儲けろ力もつけとけ肉体的にも
それだけのことをやっとったら心配すんな
もう遅いけど
[音楽]
なねもう小さい頃から頑張りましょう
甘やかされたら損したと思えしかれたらも
儲かったと思えなそん時の言い悪いじゃ
ない将来のただでどうかありがとうござい
ますござい
ます先生の男になるっていうことにについ
て伺ってもいいですかはい
いい強いという
こと女が男を求める時にどんな人がいい
ですすかて聞いて
みろ優しい人がえっていうやろじゃあ
優しい人って何なんやこれはね必然なの
強いだけの人間ができて
み相手殺しちゃうよだから自分が強くなる
と同時にじ
だけ優しくならんといかんね優しいだけの
人間ができてみ相手に殺されちまうよだ
からちょうどバランスが取れるところこれ
は強くなればええんだ強いというのは肉体
だけやないぞ精神も入るんにどうしたら
強くなる嫌なことをいっぱいやるくっ
ちゃ弱さを克服する恐怖やな恐怖を克服し
て怒りを発生させるような
能力そそう難しくない特に我々がやってる
ようなマリスポーツを使うとそいつは
できる
からしっかりと怖いこと嫌なことそれを
しっかりやって恐怖を克服
するそうするとね黙っとっても安定するん
だ安定したら能力が
出せるここは怒りでやるんやね怒りによる
行動は
正しいなそれを今怒りによる行動は間違っ
とる一生懸命あのリベラルどがそうしとし
てそんなこと
ない進歩したければ怒りで行動しろ怒りで
行動するしたければしっかりと怒りを出す
怒りが出てこんでは行動のしよがないもん
ね怒りを出す光を出すためには恐怖を克服
するこの順番でやっていくんだだから恐怖
を克服する時から
始めるどうしても方法が分からんやったら
聞きにこいよ有料や
ぞまあ頑張ろうよ君たちの時代
[音楽]
やE